how incredible does it feel to be on
season 2 of Riverdale it has been such a
success season 1 and season 2 is even
bigger it seems thanks it's kind of a
whirlwind I kind of just try to keep my
head down and focus on the work and make
sure that I'm still putting out work
that I'm proud of and kind of ignore all
the external factors that are going on
around me but I'm really proud of the
work I'm doing which is all I care about
I have to tell you in the show you are
one of my favorite characters just
because she is the I'm at a loss for
words for what to call her
but she is just such a character what do
you love about playing Cheryl that's a
great question I love her complexity is
I feel like she's got so many different
layers and she's always feeling like 15
different emotions like most human
beings are but I think on camera a lot
of the time you really see camera
characters that are really just feeling
that one thing that's shown Cheryl's
always feel like a million different
things and the writers write her so
complex and so beautifully that it's
very easy to do what I'm doing like I'm
just reading the words off the page and
then feeling the way you would feel as
Cheryl because she's got so much going
on it's really enriching as an actor
don't sell yourself short
because there are words on a page but
it's also the emotions that she put into
the character that draw people in and
people are obviously picking up on that
the show deals with so many things
there's just a season there's date-rape
there's drugs there's all kinds of
things do you think that's been
important to the success of the show
that having these realistic things that
teenagers and adults go through
unfortunately they do go through it I
don't necessarily think it speaks upon
the success of the show I think it's
important that we realize that we are
kind of shaping the minds of the youth
that watch the show and so making these
things apparent to them maybe will help
one or two kids not get date raped or
not get drugged and I think that's what
makes it important not necessarily has
anything to do with the success of the
show the show is I would say no some of
your co-stars earlier today I'd that
when I first heard the show was gonna
come on that there's two ways to show
could of what it could have been sugary
sweet and you know bring out not really
as cool as it is or could it when it's
dark yeah do you think that's the
darkness of the show is part of the
success of it as well um yeah I think
when I talk to people about the show
they're like oh yeah I watched the first
episode to see if I was gonna hate it
cuz I thought I was and then I watched
it and I was hooked and I watched the
entire season
go and that's literally the answer we
get from anyone over the age of eighteen
they always started watching it to be
like oh this shows dumb and then they
watched it they're like oh my god I'm
hooked so I think it does have to do
with the darkness and not people kind of
associate our Chi with a much lighter
universe and we've taken a completely
different take on that and I think
that's why it's so interesting so tell
me what fans can expect or you know we
have 10 or 13 episodes almost when they
say roughly what say 10 for now so what
else is what's going to come up with
Cheryl within the rest of the season
it's so interesting that you ask that
because we start what will be my
favorite episode tomorrow so Cheryl's
kind of gonna start you're gonna see a
lighter side of Cheryl a more you're
gonna learn a lot more about her past
and why she has that relationship with
her mother and you're gonna see a love
interest so I'd love to know what was
your first initiation into the world of
Archie I remember me and I would pick up
in the doctor's office or dentist's
office there would always be an Archie
comic there what was your my dad used to
cut all the sunday strips for me to
remember them in the newspaper you're
from Canada right so maybe you didn't
have them in the newspaper but in the
States we had the Sunday strips and my
dad would cut them out and put them in
front of my plate every Sunday morning
for brunch and that was kind of like our
thing and then I kind of forgot about it
and moved to LA and did my thing and
then I got this audition and like it
connected my dad and I had to an extreme
degree in he's obsessed with OSHA